you
hi everyone is cherry this is video for
from the beginner to chess master
playlist which is a progressive series
of videos and I like to discuss the
types of files in chess there are three
files and chess to be familiar with and
do know that this is an important topic
I would not be covering it if it wasn't
having being familiar with certain chess
terms the types of files in the game is
going to be quite useful to us having a
good internal dialogue in a chess game
is very important the things you think
about during the course of the game in
other words is important being able to
describe your opponent's play well being
able to describe your own moves well
will be quite insightful to you and
often will help you to know what ought
to be done in a chess game so let's move
forward here let's see what I'm
referring to when I say there are three
file types I'll be sharing that with you
providing some definitions and some
examples to go along with it so the
first file type is a closed file a
closed file by definition is one that
contains one or more white bones and one
or more black pawns and so by that
definition what we can observe here is
that the start of a chess game contains
all closed files each file here has one
or more white pawns and one or more
black pawns okay let's look at a
position that's not so familiar
something other than the start of a
chess game this one here this is an
example of a position where we have all
closed files again a file containing one
or more white bones and one or more
black pawns you'll notice I'm not
looking at all at the other pieces the
Knights the bishops the King the rooks
we look at the pawns and the pawns alone
in order to determine the file type so
you might as well envision this position
here
as if there are no pieces and it is
stripped to ponds and ponds alone this
again is an instance of all closed files
to have a look at some open files a
position that contains open files
what are open files well that's the
simplest of the three to define open
files a file that has no pons okay so we
have the C file in the G file as open
files all the other files in this
position are closed containing one or
more white buns and one or more black
pawns and lastly we have half open files
let's see what I'm referring to with
that now we could actually have a break
this part up into two when I say half
open it's really there are files that
are half open for white or half open for
black in this position the C file is
considered half open for white because
there are no white pawns but one or more
black pawns and the e file is considered
half open for black no black pawns but
one or more white pawns okay all other
files in this position are closed now
just as a close I'd like to simply go
through a game not a full game but just
a fourteen moves into some game here and
pay close attention to pawn breaks what
do I mean by pawn breaks that's just a
fancy way from a fancy way of saying
upon is captured or is doing some type
of capture like in this position here
blacks next move II takes D whenever
pawns make captures or whenever a pawn
is captured files can change okay with
the blacks last move we can now say that
this efile is what type of file half
open for black and we could already say
actually the D file here is
is half open for white no white pawns
but one or more black pawns
we have Knight takes pawn so half open
for white half open for black moving
forward sum when do we have another pawn
capture right here whenever there are
pawn captures files change we now have
the B file as half open for black
getting some more moves in here after
eat aches D this is an instance of an
open file and after that recapture well
well this position right here for just a
moment is half open for black but after
this capture here it's half open for
white so this final position let's just
get a few more moves in here this final
position we have a mix of all three file
types we have all closed files here
let's see the a file is closed the C
file F G and H those are all closed
files open files there's only one of
them the e file is opened and half open
files half open file is half open file
for white is the D file half open file
for black is the B file now why exactly
is this so important this is going to be
helpful to us in particular for Brookes
pieces that function well on open files
are the rooks and if you have an open
file such as this one here this is a
good spot for a white rook just as this
file here is a good spot for a black
rook if you can recall from video 2
where I spoke of peace mobility some we
saw that an open chess board no matter
where the rook was his maximum number of
moves is 14 while we would like to have
our pieces maximized this is a way to do
that for the rook
recognizing the file types Brooks do
well on open files and half open files
or maybe better stated if you don't have
any pawns on a particular file that's
certainly a file to look into and
placing your rook on there is often
quite good
sometimes even the Queen as well will
function well on the file but sometimes
she has to be a bit cautious of being
attacked by an opposing rook but just a
quick recap here again this is the the
main focus these three file types is all
we started out having a look at all
closed files we have an instance of some
open files here the C file in the G file
if you can envision a white rook on a1
these would be wonderful spots to go to
c1 or g1 and similarly for black getting
on these squares have a lot of different
choices and lastly we saw an instance of
half open files this one here being half
open file for white and this one here
being a half open file for black so this
is as far as I want to go we'll see how
exactly this ties in in ensuing videos
and as always I hope you got something
out of it and I will catch you in video
5 take care bye
you